chaque pilote me disait toujours si
tu as peur de voler je suis comme ouais
j'ai peur de voler je comprends la
physique on m'a expliqué mais je
m'en fous toujours je suis dans quelque chose qui est en
métal  cela pèse cependant plusieurs tonnes
qui vont à 500 milles à l'heure à quelques
milles au-dessus de la terre alors quand je monte dans
un avion je donne les clés à
quelqu'un qui va me faire voler quelque part
c'est comme si d'accord je ne fais rien à
leur sujet je ne '  Je n'aime pas monter dans des voitures avec des
gens qui conduisent que je ne sais pas si
un avion ne devrait pas être différent quel
classement positif vous savez que nous avons une histoire
d'incidents dont nous pourrions nous inspirer
et nous les recherchons tous et notre
avion fictif  l'accident est vaguement basé
sur de nombreux incidents survenus au
cours des deux dernières décennies